be pushing into a 12 plus hour day and
then some
dennis tajer is one of more than a
hundred thousand pilots in the u.s
grappling with this summer's travel
demand
it's led to chaotic scenes from long
lines at laguardia airport to seas of
baggage and frankfurt what i'm seeing
right now i have never seen in my 30
plus years at the airlines
tajer is also a spokesman for the allied
pilots association a union representing
american airlines pilots the two sides
are currently in the middle of
negotiations over a new contract and
tajer says they're understaffed and
overwhelmed there is this global
airline pilot shortage
and it's not something that can be
quickly or easily addressed
while travelers have returned there are
230 000 fewer workers across the
industry than there were before the
pandemic
we look at how all this is taking a toll
and how the industry is trying to fix
things for pilots
the root of the problem goes back to
2020 lockdowns and travel restrictions
due to the pandemic stifled most air
travel around the world to survive the
aviation industry scaled back its
workforce with the four largest u.s
carriers alone losing more than 4 000
pilots in 2020 this shortage is being
felt most acutely by regional carriers
who've pulled out of some routes with
fewer passengers restricting access to
smaller cities
pilots are being stretched at some
airlines to their
limits
henry hartevelt is the founder of
atmosphere research an airline and
travel industry analysis group
he says that this shortage has upended
the control pilots have over their
schedules each month airlines share a
roster of upcoming flights with pilots
choosing the ones they want any
remaining flights are left up for grabs
for pilots that have some extra time
they earn more money as a result when
they fly those trips
so it's a win-win for the pilot and the
airline
but the predictability of this system
broke down in the summer when the travel
season was hit by extreme weather
technical glitches and other snafus
flight schedules had very little buffer
room to deal with these unexpected
issues
some of them are 10 11 hour days that's
basically gonna give me about uh
a little over an hour of
buffer and the resulting flight delays
and cancellations left both passengers
and staff uncertain about when they
would be flying
this unpredictability has made some
pilots hesitant to take extra flights
there is a deep resistance to actually
go pick up time once you're in the
system they come in and say guess what
you're not going home you're gonna go
for another day or two
to manage a challenge facing pilots as
well as other staffing shortages across
the industry some airlines are adjusting
their scheduling
american airlines said during its july
earnings call that it would reduce
scheduled flights for at least the rest
of the year
we pulled out uh you know some
additional flying
and that's fine that we would rather do
this is a painful decision to make after
the industry spent about two years
waiting for demand to return
obviously this comes at a cost
for one thing they still have all the
pilots that they have on payroll
they got the lease or debt payment to
make on all of those aircraft and they
have all of the other employees
on staff who have to be paid
the cutting flights won't fix another
problem quickly replacing the pilot's
loss during the pandemic it's incredibly
difficult to get these wings
pilots have to go through a wide range
of tests and licensing requirements as
well as fly for 1500 hours before they
can start working for a commercial
airline a hundred thousand dollars just
to get the certification let alone the
amount of time and money you'll have to
spend to get the experience to move
forward
aviation analysts and flight schools in
the usa it can take up to two to four
years to get the required training and
experience these young pilots coming
through some of them they have to
provide for their families while they're
flying these in between jobs to get that
experience
to make this process easier american
airlines said it's focusing on removing
training and financial barriers for its
aviators through its cadet academy
and faster training will be key because
2022 is already the busiest year on
record for pilot hiring major u.s
carriers are also on track to hire more
than 10 000 of them this year according
to one pilot advisory firm
as of august american airlines alone had
hired over 1 200 pilots
the airlines are not doing nothing
they're doing all they can the challenge
is
that
they need to be doing more
as a summer travel surge begins to fade
airlines are hoping to avoid the same
snafus during the winter holiday season
american airlines said their reduced
flight schedule in the fall will give
them space to prepare for the end of
this year
and then as we go forward in the later
september october and deeper into the
winter we have time yet to go and figure
figure out how that goes
but it may be too late by then as the
summer experience has put off some
customers one survey found that 17
percent of leisure travelers said
they're less likely to fly over
christmas and new year because of
airline disruptions during the summer
this is what we are alarmed by right now
it's costing and a cost isn't just in
money the cost is in the trust
[Music]